leaders at the G7 Summit in Japan are
holding a special session on the war in
Ukraine President Vladimir zelensky has
joined the talks in the city of
Hiroshima he's already met with a number
of leaders on the sidelines of the
summit G7 leaders have agreed to tighten
economic sanctions on Moscow while the
U.S has backed the training of Ukrainian
pilots on F-16 fighter jets let's go
work live now to Hiroshima are
diplomatic editor James Bays is there so
James the G7 I think it's safe to say
has been dominated by the visit of
president zielinski what does that mean
for him and for G7 Unity against Russia
and its war in Ukraine
yeah absolutely a meeting taking place
now we've had the meeting between the G7
and president zielinski now The Wider
grouping prime minister kashida is
calling that meeting to order I warn you
we're not going to get pictures of this
for much longer because we're told we'll
see the very start of the meeting and
then they go into closed uh closed
session but we are seeing the pictures
of the meeting now and The Wider
grouping here those that have been
invited by the G7 very important for
president zielinski because they include
countries that are not in the western
Coalition yes Australia is one of the
invited countries but most importantly
countries like Brazil India and
Indonesia also in the grouping of people
attending we have South Korea Vietnam
the Cook Islands and comoros you might
wonder about those two but one is the
current chair of the African Union and
the other is the chair of the Pacific
island States for president zielinski
he's trying to persuade all of these
countries to do more for Ukraine some
countries like India I think some
observers have
would say have been somewhat on the
fence for example India abstained in the
U.N general assembly on votes that had
taken place last year on the war in
Ukraine president zielinski is hoping
his personal diplomacy here face to face
and he's been sat next to Prime Minister
Modi as you can see in the pictures his
personal diplomacy and he had a meeting
a few hours ago with Prime Minister Modi
can perhaps change things a little and
get some of these countries more firmly
on Ukraine's side of course with regard
to India India has very long-standing
defense ties with Russia which obviously
is a significant factor in the Indian
calculations on the situation regarding
Ukraine for president zielinski there is
some worrying news back home from bakmut
as I think these pictures are about to
draw to a to an end the live pictures
that we see but there is some good news
um on what's he what he's getting on the
ground certainly from the G7 Urban
partners and particularly the US the
objection on f-16s being transferred to
Ukraine seems to have been lifted by
President Biden meaning that other NATO
Nations not the US they're not going to
supply the f-16s but other NATO Nations
that have f-16s can now transfer them to
Ukraine giving Ukraine the latest ask
it's wanted which is fighter jet
something that the um the the president
of Ukraine has been asking for for some
months and we've seen this progression
over 15 months we've seen initially some
of even the NATO members saying they
weren't going to supply any sort of
lethal Aid it had to be non-lethal Aid
then we saw more sophisticated Weaponry
we saw missiles before air defense
systems then the the subject area was
tanks now it's fighter jets so certainly
it's if you look at what has happened
over the last 15 months Ukraine is
getting so much more for its defense
than it did at the start of this war and
that imp Parts must be due to president
zielinski and his tireless diplomacy
using the phone using Zoom calls video
links to begin with and now
um now he's felt that his country
perhaps is not as at the risk of
imminent
um falling to the to the Russians as it
was at the beginning
um he's able to travel he feels it safe
enough to travel and we're now seeing a
repeated
um uh shuttle diplomacy jet diplomacy uh
by President zielinski this the first
time he's visited Japan this is the
first time an in-person meeting of the
G7 and pretty significant to see the
pictures of him with the G7 leaders
those pictures I'm sure will Wrinkle in
Moscow because of course the G7 until a
decade ago and it was just a few weeks
actually it will be a decade ago in June
2013 was the last meeting of the G8 and
that that G8 used to have Russia as part
of it and President Putin attended that
last G8 that took place in Northern
Ireland in lochearn well now a decade on
Russia was kicked out of the of the G8
after invading Crimea in 2014 and now
you see those pictures of the G7 and
their president zielinski almost it
seems standing in the place where
President Putin used to stand the G7 as
we said dominated by uh this uh the
appearance of President zielinsky there
in Japan but but G7 leaders James also
issued what could be construed as a what
a thinly Veiled Threat to China accusing
it of using economic coercion to bully
several countries and those comments
have seriously angered the Chinese
yeah they taught the word coercion was
used by the G7 they also talked about
being very worried about the CIS
situation in the East and South China
Sea uh and this I think has angered the
Chinese when you look at the statements
that come out of the foreign Ministry
spokesman said the G7 was smearing China
said this was a small group seeking to
impose its rules on the world well the
G7 is in terms of seven countries
um a pretty small block but remember it
also has the EU as a member and the EU
is 28 countries and so it does represent
reasonably large population but China
angry and saying the policies of the G7
hinder International Peace damage
Regional stability and suppress
development of other countries in terms
of the scale of diplomatic outrage and
diplomatic language this wasn't
diplomatic China's very angry
our diplomatic editor James Bay is
reporting live there from Hiroshima many
Thanks James
as you heard Russia says its troops have
taken full control of the Eastern
Ukrainian city of bankwood that's after
the head of Russia's Wagner mercenary
group yevgeni priguration released a
video claiming to have seized the area
Keith denies that the city has fallen
describing the situation there as
critical ahmut has been the focus of the
longest and most deadly Battle of
Russia's war in Ukraine journalist Yulia
Shopper valova has more now from Moscow
in the afternoon of May the 20th
brigosian announced that bakmud had been
taken under the a complete control of
the Wagner group and later in the
evening he posted a video of the
installation of the Russian and Wagner
Flags in different parts of the city
however it did not show the southwestern
District where the Ukrainian military
held their positions until recently
pregosian has been in a public conflict
with the ministry of defense for several
months now and they were reports that
the state media were forbidden to quote
the businessman's statements that are
not neutral and do not directly relate
to the situation at the front it's quite
interesting that Russian TV channels and
their news bulletins on the evening of
May the 20th ignored this statement of
the head of the Wagner group about
taking Bahamut Under full control but
now they can report about that as soon
as we have the official statement from
the ministry of Defense